[inaudible]
the short answer to that question
because
when I began writing this book,
I actually had had the,
uh,
the,
the word grown up idealist is a word
that had occurred to me for a long time
in thinking about Kant and indeed in
teaching count,
I've been teaching cottonelle wow.
Gosh,
uh,
let's see.
For nearly 20 years,
uh,
on and off.
So when I was teaching college at Yale,
I used the word grownup idealist to
describe view viewers.
I've explained it to Barack Obama was
the first politician that I have ever
come across who I genuinely think has an
eye for both the way things are and the
way that things should be.
I think he embodies the American dream
in a way that we have not ever seen,
uh,
in a way that embodies both the
immigrant dream,
a sense of perspective about the rest of
the world,
combined with a genuine appreciation of
the American dream.
And I think,
I think he's,
uh,
it's absolutely brilliant.
Uh,
what convinced me about Barack Obama was
actually his first book,
dreams from my father.
And,
uh,
which is a book that I've been
recommending to people who then walk
away saying,
you know what,
even if he's not even,
he doesn't become president,
this is such a good book.
Anyone would've been proud to have
written it.
It's subtle,
it's reflective,
it's self reflective itself critical.
Um,
it's observant.
Then it's poetic.
Um,
all of which are reveal a sense of
character that I think we'll all be
proud to have in our next president.
And a final point that I have not seen
anybody raise about Obama is the
following.
Obama really does represent the triumph
of the civil rights movement.
There's racism in this country.
There is no question.
We've also seen it in the election and
electing Barack Obama will not get rid
of it,
although it will be a giant step
forward.
I think one reason why so many people of
all ages are being inspired by Barack
Obama.
Is it the civil rights movement really
is a moment that Americans in our recent
history,
the American can be genuinely proud of.
It was a genuine moral,
morally political movement with all of
its frailties.
I just saw a terrific play called the
Good Negro,
a downtown which,
uh,
talks the frailties and the infighting
and all the things that happened in the
civil rights movement.
And yet it was a unique moment.
Uh,
we don't have an instance of that in
other countries.
I mean,
you have countries throwing off
colonialism,
but you don't have a moment in which a
country looked at its own ideals and
said,
hey,
we're not living up to them and it may
be bloody and painful and hard and
reluctant,
but we're going to change because we
know that we're not living up to the
standards that we set to ourselves.
And I think a sense that this is,
this is,
this crystallizes something in America
to be proud of again,
is a perhaps what Michelle Obama meant
with her slightly,
um,
misspoken comments that I completely
understand when my own teenagers who
look at politics completely skeptically
up to now see an interview with him on
television and come to me and had been
making fun of the grownups are being
excited for awhile.
My get it,
he's for real.
And if he's elected,
it will change the world.
And I have to say,
um,
Barack Obama has made in America an
offer we couldn't refuse.